a lot of people are communicating over
the internet on their phone now not just
SMS you know messages like signal
whatsapp Facebook Messenger they all
have some kind of end-to-end encryption
these days so this is not the same as
when you go online to let's say an
online shop and you in immediately have
a conversation and set up an encrypted
connection this is much slower than that
and much more asynchronous so there's a
lot of difficulties when using instant
messaging or you know application based
messaging because we don't know really
what's going on between between the two
parties so I send you a message
theoretically some trustworthy server
takes that message or forwards its on
onto your your phone right theoretically
right how much do we trust the server I
suppose it depends on the app but but in
any case maybe we want to try and use a
protocol that means even if we don't
trust a server it's not a lot the server
can do right and that's what the signal
protocol uses and by association what's
happened in facebook instant messenger
and things like this I'll put my phone
down and we'll talk about Allison Bob
again because we always talk about
Allison Bob Mike so they want to have a
conversation via a server between
themselves right now the problem is that
maybe Bob installed the application so
he installed signal or whatsapp or
something like this six months ago and
he's just waiting patiently for some
friend to turn up and install the app as
well right I get lots of invites to
install various different chat apps most
of them I turned down because I don't
want that many icons on my phone so what
will happen is Bob will start by
installing the app and completely aside
from whoever he wants to talk to later
he's going to send a few things to the
server he's going to send a public key
that's his identity so that's his
identity public key for Bob this is
going to be a public key on an elliptic
curve like lots of the ones we've talked
about and it'll have a private component
or a private key associated with it that
will be kept to himself he's also going
to sign a public key to verify that he's
in control of his private key that's
kind of standard in cryptography and
then he's going to produce a list of
one-time pre keys remember that what he
wants to do is have key exchange
conversations between Alice or Charlie
or anyone else that comes along and he
wants to do that not knowing when
they're going to come along
so he's gonna send his parts of her
messages ahead of time to the server so
he's going to have you know one use
public key here and another one another
one and he's gonna numbered Eve or
something like this so this is one two
three and number four so these are all
public keys of which he has the private
keys stashed on his phone right on his
application now the server is going to
do this for anyone that installs the
application right this will happen
between your your your signal app and
their service or your whatsapp and their
servers and so on what will happen next
is some time down the line hopefully
Bob's made some friends and they've
agreed to talk to him on their phones so
Alice comes along and she wants to set
up a communication with Bob now the
exact same problems that Bob faced she
faces right the first one is the Bob
might have his phone switched off so she
can't start up a conversation right and
she also doesn't know where Bob is so
the server does have a server based on
Bob mobile phone number or IP address or
something we'll know how to get in
contact with him so she goes to the
server and says I'd like to talk to Bob
but can I have a pre key bundle and this
is a set of parameters from Bob or she
can use to form a communication so the
server is going to send to Alice
Bob's identity key Bob signed pre key
and one IVA at random or sequentially of
these let's say number three of these
one use keys is is going to be sent
three different public heath from Bob my
Alice is going to generate an identity
key of her own for Alice and she's going
to generate an ephemeral key which is
like a one use session key which is very
common and difficult man for herself
there all right what do all B's going to
do well let's let's get rid of this
paper or just move for sort of flopping
around so we've got a I seem to change
pens but it's not worry about that I've
got Bob's identity key that should
identify him like if we know that Bob
has the private key and we know that's
Bob the fact that this key has been used
means it must be Bob on the other end of
a line all right that's a really good
thing to know his sign pre key for Bob
this stops the server messing about of
his pre keys because he signed it and a
server can't do that and a one use
public key for Bob and what that's going
to do is make sure that no one can
replay attack Bob by sending this whole
conversation again
later what was gonna delete this when
he's seen it for the first time so when
you fetch a pretty bundle and you use it
to talk to someone on one of these apps
they will delete that pre key so that
they can never use it again and we've
got Elias we've got the identity key
from Alice and her a femoral key now I'm
going to use a different pen we've got
five different public keys here right
and we're going to perform four
diffie-hellman right which is AG a
little bit hairy but you know bear with
me to remind you we did a video on TV
Helen which you might like to watch but
what difficult as you both send public
key to each other you exchange them you
use your secrets to calculate a shared
secret so any of these two public keys
can be combined to create a shared
secret right but if you only use two of
them you're not getting the whole
picture and you're not you know for
example if you only use Bob's identity
key and Alice is a ephemeral key
you aren't guaranteeing the identity of
Alice by verifying this particular
identity key here every public version
has a private one so there's going to be
a little little private identity key for
Alice little private ephemeral key for
Alice and there you get used within the
mathematic and the same on the other
side so there's a little one for Bob so
this is identity key for Bob I've gone
out too many and this one is that it's
let's say number this was number three
wasn't it so so let's put in number
three here Bob's got a whole list of
these right so he's got a whole list of
these one two three and this is the one
he's going to use alice is gonna perform
a difficulty exchange four times right
so he's gonna do this one here she's
going to do this one here she's going to
do this one here that's number three and
she's going to do this one here number
four right so she's bringing all the
keys into play then she's going to
produce one master key shall we say with
all of these pre master secrets so she's
going to take one and she's going to
append it to two she's gonna append it
to three append it to four she's gonna
put that through something called a key
derivation function which for the sake
of simplicity we'll just say the very
similar to a hash function and that's
going to produce her master secret she
can then use that to encrypt things and
fear ethically when she sends a message
to Bob Bob would be able to do the same
thing and no one else will
right so she'll send a message including
something encrypted her identity key and
her ephemeral key Bob will do the exact
same procedure
and then he will be able to send her a
message back the way that the signal
protocol works with with Alice and Bob
and the server in between is called
triple diffie-hellman why are we doing
all these different difficulty vyas
video we just had a public key for Alice
and a public key for Bob we seem to be
wasting a lot of time well each of these
different difficulty exchanges gives us
something different but the really
important ones I want to talk about are
the ones involving these identity keys
here the identity keys prove who you are
but of course if I'm Alice and you're
Bob and I send you an identity key for
myself it doesn't prove who I am at all
I've just it's just a number it doesn't
say anything right so how do I actually
how do you actually know that the
message came from me right and the
answer is four actually what you need to
do is look at this number off line
out-of-band you need to go outside of
the normal line of communication over
the Internet
and face-to-face look at this number and
if you see that it's right then you know
they must have been me
having this conversation okay so I can
send you a message using signal right
you've installed signal your Bob I'm
Alice in this case right so you've
already sent your pre keys to the server
just waiting to go I my met my phone
will send a message a server and say can
I get a pre key bundle and then we'll
perform an exchange right something like
that so I'm gonna send you a message
it's not going to be interesting hello
all right so I send you a message
hopefully it pops up on your phone it
does there we go I mean this is good
evidence but it was me I literally sent
a message and it appeared on your phone
but that didn't always happen in instant
messaging so sometimes I'm not around or
you're not around at a time so how did
you know when it pops up my name on here
but it is me and the answer is you don't
write someone could have the server or
someone else could have intercepted
these messages and performed a
man-in-the-middle attack right the only
way we can verify it is to check out
each other's public keys by our identity
keys so the way that signal does this is
it takes the identity public key of
alice and the identity public key of Bob
and it combines them using a hash
function into a safety number right that
safety number is essentially a summary
of our two public identity keys right if
we have the same safety number that
means we're having a conversation with
the text same two identity keys which
means it must be a conversation just
between us
- that's the idea so let's have a look
I'm gonna go into my safety number and
they're the same and in in signal
actually you can press this a verified
button which says we've looked at these
out-of-band this is called an
out-of-band communication because we're
not using the normal encryption to
verify our keys so now actually when we
send messages it will show as verified
so in whatsapp it's not called a safety
number it's just called a security code
but you can see it's absolutely the same
now of course what most people don't do
it's right most people say messages in
assume there isn't a man in the middle
and in all likelihood there probably
isn't but if you want to be really sure
maybe have a look at your safety number
we've only covered half the story we
talked about this pre key bundles and
this this initial trifid triple
diffie-hellman I mean we all have phones
we talk about batteries all the time so
if you hypothetically picked four words
that were in the top 500